or some breaking news now there's been a
mass shooting in the U.S state of
Maryland at least two people have been
killed and 28 injured well Heidi Joe
Castro joins us on the phone now from
this state uh Heidi what more do we know
at this stage
well we know
where Americans in the city of Baltimore
uh were gathered late last night to
celebrate the nation's Independence
because of course it's July 4th in a few
days time police say that just after
midnight at this block party is when
they received calls about a shooting and
when they arrived they found that there
were two people dead a total of some 30
people were shot many of them actually
taking themselves to the hospital
afterwards the Witnesses are are telling
uh reporters that they they thought that
the sound of shooting of the gun firing
was fireworks
once again this is sort of the same
story that we hear repeated during these
mass shootings at public Gatherings and
of course just a year ago also on this
public holiday in the city of Highland
Park in Illinois That's when seven
people were killed while watching uh an
independence Day Parade the suspect in
that case just recently pleading not
guilty to 117 felony counts
so once again this is a repeat story
many people waking up to this news in
the U.S I should mention by the way that
the suspect in this Baltimore shooting
that just happened overnight is still on
the loose police are still on the
lookout for that person
but again the gun violence archive which
is a data project
at Northeastern University says that
each July 4th the U.S endures five mass
shootings which is defined as at least
four people injured so this is an
ongoing problem and Americans are
certainly aware of it Kerry the Pew
research firm just this week did another
survey finding that 60 percent of adults
say that gun violence in the U.S is a
very big problem and even more 62
percent say that in the next five years
they expect this problem to increase and
we just saw that play out in the last
few hours in Baltimore
okay for now Heidi thanks for that
update